[Music]
all right let's move on to instagram we
got a question here from instagram bo
has a question for us
i'm really struggling with going through
the photos on my phone what's a good way
to sort them and be minimal about it i
have a few just simple tips here let's
talk about the photos on your phone
here's a pithy answer for you
so not buying a thing is letting go in
advance now what does that have to do
with your phone
well not taking the picture means you
don't have to delete them so i have this
rule on my phone that anytime i go take
a picture of someone my daughter we go
to an event a concert whatever i will
take one photo i learned this from my
friend adam who's a photographer who
uses film photography so he doesn't want
to waste the photos by this because with
our phone we can take infinite photos
now right i'll just snap a thousand
photos i'll figure it out later well
then you get back to your camera roll
eventually and it's a mess it's
cluttered with the same photo over and
over and over and over so what i do is i
go take one photo and even oops my thumb
was actually in the picture so what
great i took the one photo and then i
put the phone in my pocket i put it on
airplane mode it's done now
even though the photo was terrible it
was blurry whatever it was i took the
photo that's my boundary i'm done and so
that's one thing i do the other thing i
do if i have any duplicates from the
past that i want to get rid of i set a
trigger for me it's any time that i am
on an airplane as soon as i sit down on
the airplane i start going through the
camera roll i delete anything i don't
want in the camera roll anymore that way
the camera roll sort of serves as my
photo album that i can reference all the
time there are no duplicates and it's
really simple i like that so much i
i almost nuked them all yesterday i my i
feel like my iphone memory is set to
tragic like i don't know where that
setting came from but it's literally
like hey remember when you were in love
and your cat was alive every day and so
i literally i mean i got some cool
pictures on there with like people i
look up to and people who aren't here
anymore but i literally i have thousands
and i'm just afraid to even look at it
and i'm like well that's not fun and so
i i am debating do i just nuke do i just
nuke it do i just nuke the whole thing
well we've got an essay on our website
you go to the minimalists.com delete if
you want to delete a thousand photos in
11 days it's real simple today all you
have to do is go and delete one photo
okay tomorrow it's twice as many photos
you keep doubling it every the next day
right
you by 11 days you're at a thousand
photos
and we've done this challenge we've had
thousands of people do this with their
smartphone camera roll so you start
there you let go of the photos that
aren't serving you anymore you spend the
time you set up that trigger so you're
deleting them regularly but then going
forward just like with your system
yeah you don't bring as many photos in
and you don't have as much to clean up
on the back end one good rule of thumb
for that is never save it unless you
intend to share it so here's an example
that we already all employ we take a
photo of ourselves and then we look at
the photo and we go oh god i hate the
way that i look right and what do we do
we immediately delete it because we're
thinking that's not going on instagram
that's not gonna be my new profile pic i
don't want anybody to see that so what
am i gonna do i'm gonna delete it right
so don't just do that for yourself and
your profile pic do that for the people
that you're in relationship with when
you get when you feel tempted to take a
picture of that tree to take a picture
of that meal ask yourself who am i going
to share this with what am i going to do
with this right after i take this
picture am i going to blow it up at
kinko's and put it on my wall as a nice
poster that adds decor to my home okay
cool am i going to send it to my friend
and be like hey dude that restaurant you
told me about i'm actually here that's
really cool if you've got something you
can do with it take the picture yeah do
the thing delete it because now you've
created a meaningful experience by
documenting this but if you're taking it
just because you're falling into the pat
right the pack rats trap of oh i have no
purpose for having this thing but i'm
gonna hold on to it because i'm too
afraid to throw it away because some
moment might arise in 20 years who knows
where i'll need this thing and i won't
ever be able to find it again that's the
trap that you can't get out of don't
save it unless you can share it yeah
dude i went hiking the other week
the preface this is gonna sound like i
was on mushrooms and i wasn't i went uh
hiking not on mushrooms and there was
this gorgeous tree and it looked so old
and big and wise and i went to take a
picture of it
and then i was like what am i going to
do with a picture of this and i put my
phone away and again i cannot stress
this to you enough i was not on
mushrooms i touched the tree instead of
taking a picture of it
and felt you don't want to do it with
people though no yeah yeah
guys i was just i was checking out this
chick i was going to take a picture and
then i just touched her um no i was
and i just touched the tree and it felt
like there was this energy i felt yeah
where
suddenly i'm thinking about the tree in
a context that i would have never
thought about before i'm like god how
long has it been here what has it
survived then i started remembering all
these like facts i've read about just
randomly like do you know when trees are
in danger they hold hands under the
earth and it was just such just like
beautiful still very quick experience
but like you think i'm gonna go back
through thousands of sad pictures to be
like i gotta find a picture of that i
would have never looked at it again i
would have posted on instagram to be
like look as i go in nature i'm woke and
that and then forgot about it and
instead
as we're talking i just remembered like
exactly what it felt like to like touch
this like gorgeous tree and i'm so much
happier that i had that experience
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free